Uh, I'm
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah,
um, in
my Rosenthal family, it's customary to hand over things that are destroyed from the jewelry and videos that the person who is the last to be at the waterfall that binds a stay.
It
means that you leave it for viewing at your own house
[Music
] By giving a sin and giving it a form, it makes more sense to come to your house.
I didn't say such a distorted thing.
I'm
going to ask you to make the one-way road a hindrance
to Adonai.
No, it's
true that my defensive power isn't very
good with this Idealization I should hand over my equipment to
others.
If you're Master Darhodo, you don't need to rely on the defensive power of good clothes, so
please
[music]
Please, I'll
be
Prime Minister of Adonai.  You don't have
to teach me either, I'll learn on my own, so I'll get sick and send it over
to become Prime Minister of Adonai.
I'm begging you.